you dare enter this house
your lucky day [__] Ash Wednesday
2017 what are you giving up for Lent
[__]
pilot to Bombardier pilot to Bombardier
pilot to Bombardier [__] uncle Joey
here Ash Wednesday I got one on my
forehead and one of my nutsack you
understand me that's the real the real
[__] Catholics wrong twende
March 1st you're done with [__]
excuses [__] 2 months and passed
and you're still there gone what's going
on with my life
get it together uncle Joey's here to
make it better and you understand me
without the Fredo look how we're
starting the day or this is the [__]
media and I'ma gettin right here I got
it at my house don't ask we got some
tremendous tweet today we got some of
this we got some [__] perennial og
today is your lucky day [__] you
understand me so you're happy that the
president fill all the voids in your
[__] week Gentile heart oh my god he
send it back who gives a [__] get up
write your goals do your push-ups and
get on with your life don't worry about
the house side [__] and see what
happens with your life you start writing
your goals down and starting off this
[__] and you'll go Joey what happened
you're not [__] around with [__]
Momo's no more you're hanging out by
yourself you're tapping beep into the
mental core of your life Joey what's
with the [__] you beaten we're gonna
Sparkle what it's coming at you
well I got this morning I spoke to both
of Jesus and I put the wheat ashes right
on my forehead you understand me I'm at
the church I could do whatever the [__]
I want but besides that it's a beautiful
day to be alive
you got the world by the ball you're
young you got nothing but heart and you
got potential don't just [__] wasted
at Starbucks I want to go to Saudi
Arabian hang out get the [__] out here
America is America [__] after you leave
Kansas call me then you go to some of
these [__] places we gotta go
to Kansas you gotta go to Michigan you
gotta go to [__] Oklahoma you gotta
go to all these states in the middle to
see how these [__] a living
before you huh well I think i'ma go to
Bangladesh and hang out with get the
[__] out of my face wait smoke a bowl
and join the real [__] world
while Sen Milo you're not with the house
to suck your dick
anyway anyway we're here with queer but
gasps seven o'clock tonight the Church
of what's happened now don't forget with
two weeks away from [__] Baltimore
Mugabe's March 16th who's better than
you Andover forget July 29th the [__]
board gotta understand me Lawrence
Kansas I love you [__] home
okay you what are you [__] nuts or
what
I gotta get my lungs together here
anyway let's do it this [__] og this
has been killing me all week this here
this is a special strand from [__]
Israel you see this disrespect to me
from [__] Israel is what they give
krav maga people before they break necks
and [__] like this hmm
the power of Christ compels you
[__]
anyway you got the world by the balls
and I smoked this bowl and go out there
and pose your will and he's [__] weak
[__] Gentiles so I'm giving up for
Lent weak [__] Gentiles who left
nobody left yet nobody left yet this
goes to prove to you what I've been
tellin you [__] for years these
Gentiles that's not that bad I thought
that that like the rest of these [__]
people have talked in the out of place
uncle joy might not be the most
intelligent admin I'm not the most
[__] verbally you know but I tell you
what
hang a lady I'm gonna tell you the true
right to your [__] face and
that's the most important thing that
everybody avoids is the [__] truth
especially these [__] people up here
but truth
he just has - get the [__] out of here
listen I was a junkie a thief and a
[__] animal I never heard that from
nobody that's what the [__] I am
felony whatever who gives a [__] I've
made my mistakes but guess what [__] I
bounced back and that's the talent
that's what a [__] thing lies
so don't let him get you down don't let
these [__] Gentiles get you down I'll
let them judge you [__] them it's your
world [__]
and when you realize that oh don't make
this journey a lot less [__] easy you
miss daddy this is your world freedom to
your [__] world
[__] all these [__] I don't we
listen I don't I don't want to do since
I was a [__] kid that's the way my
mom raised me
that's the immigrant mentality we don't
do whatever the [__] we don't get I
don't want how about I don't want to fit
him if I wanna fit in I'm gonna join the
Boy Scouts and ya down it down I don't
want to fit in I want to be [__]
uncle Joey and that's the same thing you
should be thinking today what do you say
we do want more both and we go out there
and we just make somebody choked on our
[__] nut sack today [__]
look at that
maybe if a to [__] out you'll never go
back to work you get fired because Uncle
Joe and I can't do that to you don't
stop I smoke more polish it
and I said let's go home with a
[__] day Chris today's your
lucky day you understand me today's the
day you're gonna break out of whatever
the [__] you were going through cuz
don't get me wrong we're all going
through something but every once in a
while you just wake up and say today's
the day I'm putting my dick in your
[__] nose understand me right on your
[__] ass right there huh how you like
me now [__] anyway let's do this
go out there spread the word of love be
nice to one person and that's it that's
the real deal Holyfield like that
everything else is [__] they've not
get on the bus McGeorge fool me and go
tell stories with him because trumpet
and then they tap them on the back and
they are oh my god you you've so brave
your words the [__] out of my face I
don't give a [__] about words forgiven
[__] about actions [__] seven o'clock
the Church of what's happening now is
the only action you'll need today you
understand me I love your [__]
I love you [__] thank you for
the love you give me you know I talk
from the heart in that second I don't
give a [__] I was looking for a job when
I had this one so they could all suck my
dick and they could suck your dick -
today Wednesday March 1st
see you tonight see you in Baltimore see
with Atlantic City [__] July 29th
I'll see you somewhere [__] I'm
stoned that day